choose your vehicle
trying to buy an ev in the us right now
is like trying to choose video game
character see they all have different
traits and qualities but some of them
have got this additional federal
discount option unlocked while others
haven't it's because there's legislation
that decides which cars are eligible for
a federal discount and which ones aren't
but here's the big thing that
legislation could be about to change in
a big way it's called the inflation
reduction act of 2022. it's a big deal
see the senate just passed a climate
bill that is set to completely redefine
which cars qualify for a federal
discount it's like a cheat code that's
rewriting the rules of the game
unlocking a whole new level of
previously excluded evs but at the same
time it could shut some automakers out
of the game entirely so who are the
winners and losers of this eevee
discount let's go
okay first we need to establish why some
cars qualify for the existing federal
discount and others don't it all starts
with the energy improvement and
extension act of 2008 which attempted to
encourage adoption of plug-in vehicles
by offering federal tax credits up to
7500
on qualified plug-in electric drive
motor vehicles the credit applied to any
new plug-in vehicle but not second-hand
ones and it wasn't applied when you
bought the car but instead came off your
tax bill there was also a cap that meant
the amount of credit was phased out
after an automaker sold 200 000
qualifying vehicles so as soon as tesla
sold its 200 000 car which happened
years ago uh that started to phase out
and now someone who buys a tesla doesn't
get any credit at all and that's also
happened in general motors and just
recently toyota it's that cap that's
been the source of frustration for some
automakers their argument has been we
were early on in eb sales we helped sort
of create this market why are we getting
penalized now but all of that is set to
change under this new legislation
firstly the 200 000 car cap is gone so
tesla gm and toyota would be back in the
game and the legislation now includes a
wider range of vehicles listen closely
it also gives consumers a tax credit to
buy
any electric vehicle or fuel cell
vehicle new or used and a tax credit for
up to seven thousand five hundred
dollars if those vehicles were made in
america let me break that down firstly
the new legislation extends the tax
credits to used vehicles too a whole
extra level of cars that were previously
excluded however you won't get the full
7 500 off a used car instead it's maxed
out at four thousand dollars the used
car market is a lot bigger than the new
car market it's like 70 percent of car
sales actually are exchanged on the used
market the new credit also includes
hydrogen fuel cell cars too and not just
battery evs and instead of waiting for
the discount to appear on your taxes the
credit is applied when you buy the car
but with this new approach comes new
eligibility criteria and it's this new
criteria that's really shaking things up
firstly to qualify the car would have to
be assembled in north america and then
there's restrictions over how much money
you make and how much the car costs on a
car i think it's 55 000
uh you know anything beyond that from a
sticker price standpoint
wouldn't qualify for a truck it's 80 000
and then there's income limits too
anyone with the income over 150 000 300
000 for uh married couples don't qualify
either that has been a bit of a sticking
point for some of the luxury players and
um startups like rivian rivian came out
and said almost none of our cars will
qualify now because their trucks start
around that 80 000 price tag but there's
one part of this legislation that could
render many of these vehicles ineligible
for the discount and that's new rules
that state that at least half of your
battery must be made or processed in the
united states or by one of its free
trade partners they want the industry
off of the reliance on china which is a
huge step to take because any battery
that comes in an eb is going to have
stuff that was either extracted or
processed or in some way touched by
china and this bill says if that's the
case then you don't qualify now those
battery requirements are set to come in
at the start of 2024.
that gives automakers just under a year
and a half to bolster their us battery
production or attempt to get that figure
changed so what does this mean if you're
trying to choose an ev right now well if
you're after a tesla or one of the other
brands that have been capped or you're
in the market for a secondhand dv it
might be worth waiting to see if the
house passes this bill as it could save
you money but if you're fortunate enough
to live in one of those wealthy
households or you're looking to buy a
high ndv
you might want to get in there before
the rules of the game get completely
rewritten
[Music]
you